Okay,
well so you've got this room and it's a
place that you can operate,
so it's actually a little bit of the
cosmos that's under your control and so
that's.
And you might think,
well,
it's only a room,
so who cares,
but that's the wrong attitude because
God only knows what you can do in your
room.
No orange may God only knows what you
will do in your room.
Maybe only nightmares I have about knock
her in his room.
Yeah,
but so first of all,
in order to set your room up properly,
you have to know what you're going to do
in there and that means that you have to
know what you're going to do and that
means you have to know what you should
do.
And so part of setting up your room is
figuring out what you should do.
And so that's hard because your room
should serve your purposes and if,
unless you have purposes,
then you don't know what purpose the
room should serve and you can't set it
up and then so the room should.
The room should invite you to be the way
you want to be.
When you're in the room,
so if you envision yourself the way you
would like yourself to be,
then you should build the room.
So it's the stage where that drama can
take place and then if you try to make
the room beautiful,
that will also teach you,
that will also improve your taste,
right?
Because maybe you have to buy a painting
and so you have to learn something about
art and you have to paint it and then
you have to learn something about color.
You have to learn something about
harmony and form and then you know,
you said,
well,
you're learning something about how to
regulate yourself physically and
psychologically and you're setting up
the room so that that's going to be an
easy something that you can do without
undue complexity every day.
Right?
Well that can be phenomenally useful,
you know,
because it,
let's say that that adjusts the way that
you act half an hour every day just for
example.
Okay,
so that's about three hours a week and
that's about 150 hours a year.
And so that's about three weeks worth of
work weeks per year that you've changed
in your life just by attending to the
hammock.
And you want to get that exactly right
because you actually need some rest and
you need to be creative.
And so this idea of getting your room
sorted out,
which people are,
you know,
they're,
they're having a lot of fun with and
laughing out about a lot.
It's really.
And so I'll give you a little Christian
interpretation about that too.
So,
um,
it says in the New Testament that the
Kingdom of God is like a mustard seed.
And of course a mustard seed is very,
very small,
very small.
It,
it will build itself given the proper
circumstances into quite a magnificent
and complex,
fully developed plant,
almost a tree.
And so when you make your room perfect,
and that's a mustard seed,
that's,
that's equivalent to heaven,
that's what you're doing is you're
really,
building a little microcosm of the
Kingdom of God on earth.
And that,
that will have agreed to do it
correctly.
That will have power.